oh hello I know right
hi everybody is Charlie's surprise
surprise Ryan Reynolds just dropped a
Deadpool 3 teaser for Marvel phase 5 so
I'll explain what's going on it was
probably one of the most surprising
things even though we all kind of
hopefully expected that there would be
another Deadpool movie so time to freak
out we'll break it all down and because
this is such a huge surprise in a good
way I'll give away an extra copy of The
Avengers end game blu-ray so as long as
you're a subscriber on my channel all
you have to do to enter is just leave
your best Deadpool MCU theory on the
video so what just happened Ryan
Reynolds just posted a very Easter eggs
heavy picture honoring the five-year
anniversary of when the original
Deadpool test footage leaked in the
middle of Comic Con 2014 that's how long
it's been it's been half a decade since
we saw that test footage it still holds
up today it's actually still really good
for what it was within that conspiracy
post that he made though he references a
lot of MCU people and also says
investigations heading into year 5 or as
I call it quote unquote phase 5 the
point is I love a conspiracy yarn
hashtag Lika ver siree
so there's a whole lot of meta going on
in this post here but clearly he's
trying to say the Deadpool 3 will be in
the MCU and it will happen during Marvel
phase 5 there's some more evidence from
the Marvel phase 4 comic-con panel this
past weekend that supports this I'll
play that clip in a second but if you
actually look at the picture here he
didn't upload a super high quality
version so you can't read the really
small text but you can read the really
big stuff is a mock investigation of
people who could have leaked the
original Deadpool test footage this is
where a lot of the Easter eggs are so
he's got Betty White on here because
Deadpool in the comics is a huge Betty
White Stan he loves all the Golden Girls
but he also named both of his katanas be
and Arthur a couple years ago she also
did that funny promo for the first
Deadpool movie when it came out in
theaters once in a generation a movie
comes along that your whole family will
love if your family is a hood up group
of kissing you
he's got Deadpool from Wolverine Origins
because he can't resist any attempt to
make fun of himself in that movie Rob
Liefeld because he's the creator of
Deadpool Hugh Jackman because of course
you can't make a Deadpool conspiracy
post without invoking Hugh Jackman at
some point Blake Lively is on here
because she's Ryan Reynolds wife in real
life and they make fun of each other on
social media especially when he's on
press tours for the Deadpool movies
although I think some of their posts
from the first Deadpool movie are a
little bit funnier
Tim Miller's on here because he was the
director of that first Deadpool movie
but he also worked at the special
effects house that made the actual test
footage that was leaked Rhett Reese and
Paul Wernick down at the bottom are on
here because they were the writers on
both of the Deadpool movies and they
were the writers that were hired years
ago for the Deadpool movie that Fox did
not wind up making after Wolverine
Origins blind Al's another suspect take
out what T D is on here to which is
another subtle Marvel MCU Deadpool
reference also after thor ragnarok came
out take out what TD expressed an
interest in doing a Deadpool movie in
the future even though he's making Thor
4 next he definitely has an opportunity
to make a Deadpool movie if he wants to
read up after a thor for the really
obscure turk 1/8 to reference at the
bottom is actually a reference to an old
movie where someone gets revenge on a
bunch of bureaucrats by adopting a
secret identity in harassing them he
winds up creating all this awareness and
eventually is lauded as a hero by the
people he becomes the hero of the movie
even though he seems like the villain at
points so the Turk in this conspiracy
Deadpool situation is the person who
actually leaked the Deadpool test
footage which if you guys didn't know is
actually Ryan Reynolds himself if it
wasn't clear a long time ago Ryan
Reynolds has never publicly said oh it
was definitely me that did it he's never
admitted to it but that's part of this
big conspiracy joke like he knows that
he's the one that did it but he's trying
to make it seem like he's investigating
someone else who may have done it to
throw everyone off the scent the actual
story of the leak is that prior to the
leak happening going back to 2005 Ryan
Reynolds learned that Fox wanted to make
a Deadpool movie because before Disney
got all the characters back recently Fox
had access to hundreds and hundreds of
characters to make movies with and
they'd only been doing the core x-men
character so they wanted to branch out a
little bit more so when they got to
Wolverine Origins Ryan Reynolds campaign
to be Deadpool in that he won the role
and originally the intent was is that
his Deadpool Wade Wilson character would
get a spinoff directly from Wolverine
Origins about a year after that movie
came out Rhett Reese and Paul Wernick
the people that wrote both the Deadpool
movies were initially hired to write
that spin-off Deadpool script within
about a year of that Tim Miller was
hired to develop the Deadpool test
footage they shot it by 2012 so that's
how old the Deadpool test footage is the
project stalled for about the next two
years while Fox tried to figure out
whether it was ballsy enough to try and
release a rated R film so the Deadpool
test footage just sat on someone's hard
drive for two years until Ryan Reynolds
leaked it during Comic Con 2014 to prove
to the Fox executives that there was a
very high demand for rated R version of
Deadpool you all probably remember that
weekend it was all anybody was talking
about for a couple days like what is
this secret Deadpool movie that you're
denying us give us what we want so after
all the craziness Fox finally gave them
the green light to fully develop what
would become the first Deadpool movie in
the rest was history but if you were
listening really carefully during the
Marvel comic con panel last week there
was a little more evidence that gave you
an idea for what their plans for Marvel
phase 5 were where Kevin Feige talks
about things that are coming up in a
really joking manner like here I'm going to
tease all this stuff but we can't
actually talk about it yet
there's no time lapse to talk about a
mutant
that was all ripe of word he announced
the new blade movie with Maher Sheela
Ali so he jokingly said that we don't
have any time to tell you about
fantastic four movies that were working
on or about mutants when he said mutants
he was referring to the Deadpool movies
that they'd be making and the x-men
characters that they'd be making movies
with the really good thing about all
this though is that he's spent way more
time talking about what their long-term
Deadpool plans are than he has about the
x-men characters he's been way more
mysterious about the core x-men
characters all good news though just to
summarize what most of his statements
have been that he's a really big fan of
what Ryan Reynolds and those people have
been doing with the Deadpool movies and
right now their policy is basically
don't fix it if it's not broken so I
think we can all agree that the x-men
are broken as a franchise Fantastic Four
has been broken as a franchise so of
course we want them to fix those things
we do not want them to mess too much
with Deadpool but because there's so
much money on the line here sometimes
you just don't know until you actually
see it which is part of the reason why
they did that once upon a Deadpool
experiment the pg-13 cut of Deadpool to
the holidays thought it'd be fun
while pg-13 it's a family movie also
money also Disney so yeah it is totally
possible that Disney could continue
releasing dual cuts of Deadpool like at
some point do a Deadpool three that's
rated R but then also release a home
video version this pg-13 but in terms of
MCU even though Deadpool 3 would be
within the MCU scope of films the best
thing that we've heard from the Disney
CEO is as they do intend on releasing
more Deadpool rated R films the thing
that you should take away from this
though is that the Deadpool will
continue to be rated R the only thing
that's really going to be different with
him in the MCU is that they'll just give
him access to characters and things that
he wouldn't necessarily have had access
to when the companies were still
separate and Fox still controlled all
those characters but as a consequence of
him being rated R in the traditional MCU
films being pg-13 don't expect him to be
rated R when he crosses over into other
MCU films his films might be rated R in
characters that cross over into that
might be a little more hardcore but he
himself if he showed up in an Avengers
movie which he eventually probably will
that's when he would have to be pg-13
and if you want to know what that feels
like and you haven't watched Once Upon a
Deadpool check that movie out because
that's basically what it would feel like
I need you almost as much as you need I
don't need you and all me to untie you
once we're done hey easy sugar mouth
really early speculation prediction
though we see Deadpool three before we
see the next Marvel Fantastic Four film
because they already have all the
Deadpool characters they just need to
write a new script and shoot it they
still have to cast the Fantastic Four
and figure out what they're going to do
with that movie I'm working on an Iron
Man shang-chi Easter Egg video that
should post in the next day in a
spider-man 3 video congratulations Bret
nolfi you're the giveaway winner from my
last big video please email me on the
about page of my channel so I can get
your contact details click here for that
Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness teaser and click here for more
Avengers endgame deleted scenes and
alternate endings thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome maximum effort!